how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have some very exciting things to
talk about today including an Avengers
in-game official trailer to update and
some exclusive Avengers endgame content
coming out very soon so like I said very
exciting things to talk about plus I'll
be announcing the giveaway winner at the
end of this video so be sure to stick
around so if you've been watching my
videos and been staying up to date with
everything in regards to Avengers and
game you know that Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios came out and
said that we will be getting an official
trailer 2 for Avengers in game I told
you I'd update you if I learned more and
we now know that the Avengers in game
trailer 2 will be coming out after
Captain Marvel hits the theaters many
people were expecting it before Captain
Marvel came out or as it hit the
theaters but according to what I've
heard it's going to be coming out after
and although a specific date is not
known the timeframe has been narrowed
down between March 11th and March 21st
this makes sense because they don't want
Avengers in game to overshadow Captain
Marvel especially since Captain Marvel
will be in Avengers endgame so if it
comes out on March 11th that'll give
Captain Marvel a few days in the theater
however the reason it is believed to be
coming out before March 21st is a
separate update all on its own and that
is because we will be getting an empire
exclusive for Avengers in game on March
21st the Empire exclusives last year for
Avengers infinity war were insane
last year Empire magazine for Avengers
infinity war gave us some up close and
personal looks at the Avengers that we
had not seen previously it was also
where we got our first up-close look at
Tony Stark's new nanotech Ironman suit
and of course in the articles that
accompanied the pictures we got brand
new information about the movie as well
so that's what's coming out on March
21st and although we probably won't be
getting the same amount of information
that we got for Avengers infinity war
about avenues endgame we still should be
getting some exclusive photos and a tiny
bit of information at the least about a
vineyards in game Marvel really is
trying to do everything they can to keep
us in the dark as much as possible about
Avengers in game so again we probably
won't get as much
as we got for infinity war but it's
still really exciting nonetheless so
that's it for the update again be sure
to be on the lookout for the trailer
between March 11th and March 21st and of
course be sure to grab a copy of Empire
magazine on March 21st and come back
here for a complete breakdown of all the
new info we got and of course be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers ingame
and Marvel and congrats to nicole
kuroiwa for being the IMAX ticket
giveaway winner
be sure to email me in the email in my
description and I'll get you your prize
and for the rest of you don't worry yes
I'm still doing the IMAX ticket giveaway
starting a new round with this video so
if you'd like to enter for your chance
to win a 5 imax tickets so you and some
friends can go see Avengers endgame all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]